oh
That is so cool. What's up guys welcome back for another beautiful day of experimenting in this video
We're going to revisit a failed experiment from before and turn it into a success now
I've noticed  in my last couple of videos the comments have been blowing up with people asking [me] to put liquid nitrogen in a vacuum
chamber. You probably remember
We did this in a previous video
And we didn't have any success [at] all no matter how long we round the vacuum pump or how hard we tried
We just could not get the nitrogen to freeze but today is going to be different because today I
Guarantee success. Now I have to admit that the first time we tried [putting] liquid nitrogen into a vacuum chamber
I really thought it was going to freeze
I didn't see any reason why it wouldn't because there's plenty of videos online of people getting it to work all the way from
Science laboratories to vacuum Chamber channels to cody's lab so when we experienced such catastrophic failure. I was very discouraged and wondered
Why so here's what I did I reached out to my friend cody from cody's lab to see what suggestions he had and he said
The problem was this thing right here
Look how big this cookie jar is look
How much volume it takes up and look at the size of our vacuum pump this container with this pump?
Just doesn't work. The theory is that our little vacuum pump
Just can't pump fast enough to keep up with the size of this jar
So the solution really is as simple as grabbing a smaller jar
so a big shout out to my friend cody from cody's lab for the suggestion on using a smaller jar because today we're gonna to
Put that to the test and it's going to work
So here we are guys
I just took a styrofoam cup filled up with liquid nitrogen and got myself one of these little wine glasses
[I'm] going with the wine glass because got a nice large base
And should help keep the nitrogen insulated and high up off the ground now before we jump into trying to make this work
I want to quickly address some of the comments
I saw the last time we attempted making this work some people thought the reason it wasn't working is because we actually need to [add]
pressure
rather than reduce it that [would] actually have the
Opposite effect than you think it would and I'll tell you about it in just a minute, but first let's get to pouring our nitrogen
So the nitrogen is in our cup, and I think just to cool down this container
I'm going to add a splash of nitrogen to the jar itself
We don't want to freeze the glass we just want to cool down the atmosphere inside
[it] stuff. That's just going to help the atmosphere and the cookie jar cool down a little bit so it's not quite as warm
So our glass [is] cooled down you can see it's about halfway full
We'll just top [it] up a little bit more and we're going [to] set that down inside
And you can see [I] got lucky because the top of this glass is just barely understood level of our proto [potti] there which means
We can stick this thing on top now right now. What's happening is the nitrogen is boiling?
It's actually turning into a gas and it's creating pressure, and if I were to hold this thing on hard enough
It would actually create a gas that wants to escape too much pressure and the container would explode if I open this valve here
You can actually feel the nitrogen vapor pushing out and building pressure
Because that gas is expanding so rapidly we need a vacuum pump you that can suck it in faster than its expanding but in this
Case where I've got a smaller vacuum pump?
We should be able to achieve the same effect by using a smaller container at least that's the theory all right
So we've got our valve set this one is open so it can draw a vacuum and this one is closed to prevent any air
from getting in so now all we have to do is fire up the vacuum pump let it suck out all the nitrogen vapor and
Then give it about a minute to react
All right here. We go game on
You see it starts pulling the vacuum right away. We're already about
Almost 15 inches of Mercury and the nitrogen actually starts accelerating in the way that it boils it actually boils more rapidly
What's happening?
Now is all the energetic molecules in there are being released and pulled out [of] the nitrogen and what that's doing is making the nitrogen
Itself actually colder and if we pull out enough of those vibrating molecules it should get to the point where it [actually] freezes
21 inches of Mercury, and I'm thinking we should start seeing something happen in
The next few seconds there look at that the nitrogen has gone completely quiet, and the top layer [just] froze
Yeah, yes that is often so right there about 22 inches of Mercury is where we start seeing the frozen [nitrogen]?
That's really cool guys about 22 inches of Mercury
And we saw the top layer start to freeze and then kind of exploded and then refroze and exploded and refroze again
You'll notice the whole thing didn't freeze
It was just the top layer and everything underneath. It was still liquid, but if we let it run long enough
[we] can actually extract enough heat energy to turn the whole [thing] into nitrogen snow
So right now. We're about 20 almost 22 inches of Mercury
And we should see you can see the the liquids gone completely calm. [it's] stopped boiling
and now if you watch very carefully
You see the whole top layer crystallized. [oh], that is so cool
It's got this amazing cycle of freezing and then it explodes then freezes and explodes again
But that's not even the cool part. We are just getting started
So I've had this thing running for about three minutes now
You can see the top layer of the nitrogen is completely frozen
But everything underneath it is still liquid now if we keep letting this run long enough
We should be able to get the entire solution to freeze into a glass full of nitrogen snow
And that is my goal for this project today
You want to kind of want to do is switch glasses and keeping it freeze that quicker?
Next [turn] the top for a second okay watch this it looks grateful
That's pretty, huh?
Alright. [this] is where the magic happens. [it's] gonna look really cool
You feel that's just boiling like crazy the nitrogen is going nuts. Oh
Here we go. It [was] start and see it freeze cool. That looks really cool
You can actually see the layer of ice floating on the top there
And you can see it still bubbling up from underneath because digging down now and extracting any
Energetic Molecules and allowing them to escape and as it starts doing that [we'll] see that layer of ice
begin to thicken and start freezing from the top down
we're getting pretty close to the bottom there and
What I'm noticing is the ice freezes
It actually moves upward as well because I think you know somehow I wouldn't say it's adding air to the mixture
But the way, it's freezing the crystal structure is expanding so you can actually see it's rising up
Hmm
That is really cool. So guys we did it
We actually froze our liquid nitrogen completely solid it's at the point now where?
there's no more liquid the whole glass is completely full of nitrogen snow and
Nothing is moving any longer
I have to wipe down the sides of the glass because the chamber is cold enough that the moisture in the air is condensing to
It making it difficult to see in but I think it's very apparent from this angle
We have just frozen liquid nitrogen what you're looking at here is solid nitrogen. Which is very very cool now watch
What happens if I close this valve and turn off the pump?
You can see it maintains a vacuum pressure if I wipe this down so you can get a better look
You can see it still stays in its snowy state as long as there's a little bit of pressure
But you got to remember the nitrogen is still warming up and as it warms up
It's going to release gas which increases the pressure which is going to make this thing [liquify] over time
Yeah, you can already see it's starting to warm up
The liquid is starting to boil at the bottom again, and this was with nothing happening the vacuum pumps, not running
I'm not letting any air in this is just [it's] sitting by itself
So right now. We're literally melting nitrogen ice cubes [a] little bit easier than the [last] time we tried it. [oh]
Yeah there goes
Still looks a little bit slushy over here. I'm going to get that back into a nice form
So I've just closed the valve and I've turned off the vacuum pump now over time it will warm up
It will begin to melt but watch how dramatic the change is if we open the [valve] and let all the air rush back in
holy heck
Wow
Okay, so I'm going to let the air in a little bit, too quickly
they created a vortex and all the nitrogen went spewing but you can see it turned from ice to liquid in a fraction of a
Second let's try that again, but this time let's let the air in a little bit slower, so we can actually watch the nitrogen melt
Okay, set this guy off here we go
as absolutely beautiful
look how cold that God that was amazing guys like when we let the pressure and you could actually see [the] ice melting and
The slower we did it the slower we could get it to melt and now we're left with is this super cold
Liquid nitrogen and this stuff is really special because it's actually colder than regular liquid nitrogen for example. We take this cup here
We pour in Regular Liquid nitrogen
You can see it jumps up to a roaring boil even after it cools the glass down it boils dramatically
But the stuff we [just] pulled out of the vacuum chamber is completely quiet. It's completely still [not] moving at all
That's because this liquid is actually colder than the boiling point of nitrogen how cool is that [so] [here]?
We are guys we have successfully created
Solid [nitrogen] right in the comfort of our own home and we learned a few things as we did
We started this experiment a couple months ago, and we tried putting liquid nitrogen in a vacuum chamber
[but] unfortunately we couldn't get it to freeze but in the comments section of that video some of you inspired me to either use a
Larger vacuum pump or a smaller container so in this experiment
We went to a smaller container, and we found that it worked
Not only did we get the surface of the nitrogen to freeze?
But we froze the entire cup we discovered nitrogen goes through some interesting changes as it freezes as well once it freezes it seems to
Explode back into a liquid and then refreeze once again, but after repeating this cycle a few times
We saw that all the liquid did eventually freeze?
We learned that this happens because as you reduce the pressure around the nitrogen itself all the molecules with the most energy are free to
Leave and of course by allowing the warmer Molecules to escape only the colder ones are left behind
causing the liquid to freeze
We also saw [that] if we stop drawing a vacuum for a long [enough] period [Of] time the nitrogen would warm back up create pressure
And melt back into a liquid the same thing was true if we [opened] the valve and let the Air come back into the container
The nitrogen ice melted pretty much at the same rate. We let the pressure back in and one final observation
We made with the liquid nitrogen that comes out of the vacuum [chamber] is actually colder than liquid nitrogen on its own because it's [actually]
Cooled down well below its boiling point and of course. I want to give a big shout-out to our friend Erin Greenham
Who is one of hundreds of people asking for this experiment, Erin?
You can go check your youtube inbox because I'm sending a twenty five bucks
So there you have it guys now you know how to freeze liquid nitrogen using common materials and things we made around
Thanks for joining [for] this experiment. Thank you so much for your requests. I'll be looking for you [in] the next video. [talk] you that
What is the good pull absolutely nothing?
whoa